- You asked me to watch
South Park medical scenes.
I said, "Get this
comment to 10,000 likes."
And you did it, so let's watch it.
(claps once)
Bewoop!
- No shots! No shots!
- Eric, you have to be a big boy.
- Big boys get a toy from the toy chest.
- See the doctor's getting it wrong.
You have to give the toy
first, earn the trust,
then have the shot be injected.
(hip hop beat)
(Eric screams)
- And don't let them visualize the shot.
It's scary to look at that.
Keep it on the side, keep
it out of their vision
and have them look elsewhere.
(Eric screams)
(glass breaking)
This is like a scene
out of a horror movie.
(Eric screams)
(Eric squeals like a pig)
(papers rustling)
- I'm sorry, but I have a
lot of other patients to see.
We'll just have to try again next week.
- Come on, Eric, we're going home.
- We're going home? You promise?
- Let's go, get in the car!
- Why is he still nude?
And no, you shouldn't leave the office
just because the child
doesn't want the vaccinations.
Vaccinations are an incredibly
important part of growing up
and growing up healthy and safe.
So yes, please get your
children vaccinated
and don't let them walk around nude
in a medical office like that.
That's just strange.
- What have we got?
- Not sure, looks like
a possible code 5-6.
- Kitty, shut up Kitty.
- I'm not sure if he has pink eye?
Or is that like a
subconjunctival hemorrhage?
Which is actually really
benign in most cases.
The way that the paramedics
brought him in there,
pretty legit,
minus the fact they said he's code 5-6.
That is not medical jargon.
I'm sorry, South Park.
- Get me 50 ccs of ketamine STAT!
And get something for the kid, too.
(Dr. Mike laughs hysterically)
- Oh that was actually really funny!
Ketamine is a tranquilizer.
It's technically a, it started
as an animal tranquilizer,
and now we've actually
found some medical uses
for it in humans.
I actually have a whole video on this
talking about how ketamine infusions
are being used for
treatment-resistant depression.
Link down below.
- His EKG is showing
that he's like a failing
stock market stock.
What is happening?
And his EKG next to his bedside,
I don't even know what that is.
That's not a medical rhythm.
- I'm afraid he's running out of time.
(medical instrument beeps)
- Why? What's wrong with him?
- It's his time. It's running out.
(Dr. Mike laughs)
- Well, what does he need?
- He needs to have more time.
- Oh my God.
This reminds me of the movie Out of Time
with Justin Timberlake.
That was such a good movie.
Where like, time is money.
Literally time was money,
because time is money.
But money is not time.
And then if you have enough time,
you run out of money.
I'm lost.
(Eric screams)
- Poopsy-kins?
(panicked yelling)
- Sweety, what is ?
(Mother screams)
- I'm ginger!
- Oh my God! Eric!
- Help me!
Help me!
- Is this a medical condition?
- Well, all his vital
signs are still normal.
From his outward appearance
I would say he has the standard
skin pigment deficiency.
- You mean?
- Yes.
I'm afraid that your son is
suffering from ginger-vitis.
- But how could I become a ginger now?
- It's a play on gingivitis,
which is inflammation of the gums.
But there's actually been
a lot of misconceptions
about folks who have red hair.
Specifically in the medical community.
There was a thought
where they tested
individuals with red hair
and they found that they
required more anesthesia
than other patients.
However, once we've expanded the research
to have more patients,
we found that to be completely untrue.
So there's a lot of myths
about folks with red hair,
of them being emotional,
needing more medication for anesthesia.
None of this is proven.
What's the saying, Sam?
When something is like,
like, legend has it.
- [Sam] Urban legend.
- It's an urban legend.
- You need to understand there is no cure.
Your son will be ginger his whole life.
- For individuals who
do have very light skin,
pale skin like this,
and for individuals who have
a high number of moles on their body,
you actually are at a higher risk
for developing skin cancers and sunburns.
So please, shade is your friend.
SPF is your next best friend.
- You're gonna have to take
certain precautions now.
It's very important that you
keep Eric out of the sun.
- Oh. My favorite part about that
is not that he confirmed my diagnosis
of being careful with the sun,
But the fact that
he went to the University
of the Mountains.
- I don't know what to do, Sharon.
They want to have him go into surgery
but that's so dangerous.
- Sheila, have you tried
holistic natural medicines?
They work wonders.
I read all about it in People.
- Really? In People?
- There's a brand new shop in town
that sells holistic medicines
and all natural foods.
It's run by this fascinating
woman named Misinformation.
- That reminds me of
Goop. I don't know why.
I'm getting Gwyneth
Paltrow vibes from this.
Although I have one major correction here.
Holistic does not mean frou-frou..
Holistic does not mean naturopathic.
Holistic means whole person.
In fact, when I treat my patients
I treat them with holistic care.
I give them medical care.
Sometimes it's a natural
lifestyle-based approach.
Sometimes it's a
medication-based approach.
Sometimes it's surgical.
If a person comes in with a heart attack
I don't just say, "Oh, that's
the heart attack patient."
No, we think about what's
going on in their lives.
How can they eat better?
What can they do to start exercising
once it's safe to do so?
What medication should they be on?
Can they afford these medications?
What's going on in their personal life?
Like, if you think about
all these variables,
you're going to have a better chance
of getting that person healthier.
Wow. I just went on a
rant about South Park.
- You see the reasons our bodies
fail is because of toxins.
- Toxins?
- All the horrible food we eat.
The sodas and meats
are filled with toxins.
And the only way for us to get better
is to flush those toxins
out of our system.
- And I wonder how we get rid of toxins?
We have body parts that
actually do it for us!
Surprise, surprise!
The lungs do it.
The kidneys do it.
The liver does it.
It gets out those evil toxins.
You know what's funny about
the trigger word toxins?
You know you can scare people
into buying something
that they don't need.
You don't even know what a
toxin is when you say it.
Like water is an essential
component of my being.
But if I have too much of it
I can actually dilute my
body's electrolytes so much so
that I can kill myself, essentially,
by drinking too much water.
The toxicity of a substance
can really only be dictated by the dose.
So don't let people scare you
when they throw around words like that.
- Mrs. Baflowsky would
like to give your son
herbs that focus on the kidney.
I have these excellent herbs
from local Native Americans.
- Ooh, Native Americans.
Now they know how to heal
the body spiritually.
- Ho did it go from holistic care
to spiritual care in one herbal second?
- Hi, Doctor.
- What can I do for you?
Well, it's my friend, Kyle.
I think he's really, really sick.
- He is really, really sick, Stanley.
Your little friend Kyle
needs a kidney transplant
or it is very possible that he will die.
- Why does Kyle need a kidney transplant?
That's an aggressive procedure.
Like, he needs to have something
tremendously wrong with
both of his kidneys
to need and warrant a kidney transplant.
I need to know the indication for this.
I'm taking this too seriously.
- There's only one person in South park
with the same blood type as Kyle.
- Who?
(Dr. Mike laughs)
- Kyle's in trouble, Cartman.
I can see him getting
worse right before my eyes.
There might be a way that
you can save his life.
- Uh huh?
- What Kyle really needs is a new kidney.
Will you donate one of
your kidneys to Kyle?
♪ No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no! ♪
- You only need one, fatboy!
♪ No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no! ♪
- Dude, one of your
friends is going to die.
Don't you see how serious this is?
- For the record:
Humans have two kidneys,
and only need one kidney to live.
In fact there are some individuals
who actually have only
one kidney and do great,
but if something happens to their kidney,
like it could happen to anybody else
to both of their kidneys,
they don't have a backup.
So it becomes more dangerous.
- Free-range Aspirin!
- All natural cell phones!
- Free-range Aspirin.
It just hit me what that is.
(Dr. Mike laughs loudly)
I dunno why I found that so funny.
- Oh, hi, Stanley.
Look, I'm buying you some
more all natural toothpaste.
- You mean the stuff
that tastes like (bleep)
and doesn't fight cavities?
- That's right.
- Look, um, I know that you all think
the earth and its natural
healing powers can cure Kyle,
but the doctor at the
hospital told me it can't.
- Well of course the doctor told you that
because he wants to make money.
Holistic medicine is about nature!
- And it's free!
Yet she's standing in
front of her cash register
asking for a deposit!
- $233
- For $233!
- Okay, here we go.
Okay. Well, here goes nothing.
Help me pull his pajamas up.
- Okay.
I think this goes without being said.
Don't get a wood saw
and operate on your friend
who needs a kidney transplant
at home.
I don't know who needs to hear that,
but I'm just putting out
there into the ether.
(children shouting "Hooray!")
(alarm bell ringing)
(Eric yawns)
(Eric yells)
- That son of a (bleep)!
- Who just wakes up from
a nap missing a kidney?
- Give me back my kidney!
- Dude, please, Kyle needs it.
- It's mine!
Not yours, mine!
Give it back right now or
there's going to be hell to pay!
- Alright, alright, here.
- That actually looks like a good kidney!
Wow! Well done, South Park.
- Why hello there, Eric.
(kidney hits table)
- You see that? That's mine!
Stan took my kidney and
I need to put it back in.
Please.
- Oh, I see.
Are you sure now that it's already out
you don't want to just let
your friend Kyle have it?
- No, because it doesn't belong to Kyle,
it belongs to me.
It's mine!
- Well, alright then, we'll
get you prepped for surgery.
If you'll just sign this release.
- Thank you.
(pen scribbles)
- How are you feeling, Bobby?
- Better, thanks.
- You look a lot better.
- Yeah, it looks like Western
medicine really did the trick.
- Kyle's all better,
Cartman, thanks to you!
- Huh?
- It was all a trick.
Your mama did the kidney blocker
and then we put ketchup in your bed
so you'd think we took your kidney.
- Yes, but it was all just a trick
to get you to come in
and sign this release.
- What's worse:
Nurse Jackie in the
episode that I watched?
If she forged his Oregon donor certificate
on the back of his license, that's crazy.
Or them tricking Cartman
to sign away his own kidney
by thinking he's actually
getting his kidney put back in?
What is happening with
the ethics on these shows?
I also watch Simpsons
and review the medical
scenes in that bad boy.
Check it out and enjoy the laugh.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
I just want to say bewoop
one more time, Bewoop!
(slow hip hop beat)